All right, I want to check in briefly with
you guys about the comedy of errors that are
Donald Trump's sworn affidavits, some of which
are arguing in Michigan that the results in
Minnesota towns prove Michigan voter fraud.
Now, if if you just heard me say that in your
confused, you should be confused.
It makes no sense.
And I'm going to explain it to you.
Let's back it up a little bit.
For weeks now, Trump and people around him,
including his lawyers, continue to refer to
supposedly sworn affidavits signed under penalty
of perjury from all sorts of different people
that prove that there was voter fraud.
Now, I've already talked to you before about
affidavits as evidence.
Affidavits are a form of evidence.
It could be trustworthy.
It might not.
Affidavits might be credible or they might
not.
Affidavits might be admissible or they might
They're not proof of anything per say.
But when you actually start looking at some
of these affidavits, it becomes cartoonishly
farcical.
Here is one such example.
This is just one now.
They claim to have I don't know if it's thousands
or tens of thousands of these sworn affidavits
of people reporting wrongdoing and mathematical
anomalies or anomalies, as your preference
may be for pronunciation.
But let's just look at one, OK?
There is an affidavit from a guy named Russell
Ramsland, who is a supposed expert on cybersecurity.
In his affidavit, Russell attacks Dominion
Software, which is used on some voting machines.
And it claims that there is very suspicious
activity in some towns that are in Wayne County,
Michigan, and in their list of towns in Wayne
County, Michigan.
They list places like Spruce Grove Township
and Atlanta Township and Grundberg Township.
All of those places are not even in Michigan,
as Jake Tapper from CNN pointed out on Twitter.
Spruce Grove Township is in Minnesota.
Atlanta Township is in Minnesota.
Grundberg Township is in Minnesota.
Now, one argument was this was supposed to
be evidence from Wayne County, Minnesota,
not Wayne County, Michigan.
So the everything is accurate.
It's just they put me instead of men.
And that's why all of the towns that are listed
are actually in Minnesota instead of in Michigan.
That doesn't pass the sniff test because there
is no Wayne County in Minnesota.
So what we have here is if we want to be as
charitable as possible, we have incompetence.
If we want to maybe think of a less charitable
interpretation, these are straight up fraudulent
affidavits.
The idea that they submitted these, knowing
that these are not even actually places in
Michigan and they were hoping to deceive courts
and hoping to move some of these bogus lawsuits
forward, we don't know.
We may never know.
It's increasingly irrelevant.
This evidence supposedly from Michigan was
submitted as part of a filing in Georgia.
The Georgia results are moving forward and
it was supposedly data from Michigan.
Michigan has also now been certified and put
officially in Joe Biden's column.
So it is all failing.
But this is why, you know, we really have
to go beyond there's this idea of just throwing
large amounts of stuff at the wall and seeing
what sticks.
And I've talked about this before in debate.
It's something called the Gish Gallop.
You throw a bunch of stuff out there and just
make it appear overwhelming and make it difficult
for whoever you're trying to convince to really
go step by step, step and refute this.
The equivalent of the Gish Gallop is just
getting thousands or tens of thousands of
signed affidavits and, you know, holding them
up as stacks of paper as Trump cronies have
done on television and including his press
secretary, Kayleigh McEnany.
But what you really need to do is not say,
wow, if there are 10000 of these things or
one hundred thousand or five thousand, whatever,
there must be something to it.
You just have to dove in and start looking
at it and saying, OK, let's look at this one
affidavit and then you look at it and you
say, this really is nothing.
This is really hearsay.
It doesn't really tell us anything about there
being fraud.
It's an allegation in many cases, an allegation
which, even if true, would not impact the
results of this state.
And you put that aside and then you look at
the next one and then you look at this one
and it lists towns supposedly in Michigan
that are actually in Minnesota.
And then you start eliminating it.
And what do you have left?
You have left the realization that Joe Biden
won because he got more votes in enough states.
That's really it.
And these wee rest assured.
We're not going to have to hear that much
more about affidavits for too much longer